hi I'm Jennifer I almost got kidnapped
in China trying to go to the Great Wall
one moment where I had a guy follow me
for 15 minutes trying to get me to go
into his car and he had like Five Guys
waiting hi I'm Kelsey I was searched by
the Italian police some other tourists
realized that their phones were missing
and so then they called the Italian
police the bus was pulled over they had
us all get off and then they searched
every single member of us my name's Kate
I was lost out of bounds in the back
country on a mountain in Whistler
in 2012 I went to the Vancouver Olympics
for work while I was there we were
working on a film we took a helicopter
high up in the mountains I was dropped
off at a certain point to be able to
capture the moment of them coming down
the slope what year were you born 1986
okay